Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Through over 200 episodes of this series,
we talked about many learning-based algorithms
that are able to solve problems that previously
seemed completely impossible.
They can look at an image and describe what
they depict in a sentence, or even turn video
game graphics into reality and back.
Amazing new results keep appearing every single
week.
However, an important thing that we need to
solve is that if we deploy these neural networks
in a production environment, we would want
to know if we're relying on a good or bad
AI's decision.
The narrative is very simple: if we don't
trust a classifier, we won't use it.
And perhaps the best way of earning the trust
of a human would be if the AI could explain
how it came to a given decision.
Strictly speaking, a neural network can explain
it to us, but it would show us hundreds of
thousands of neuron activations that are completely
unusable for any sort of intuitive reasoning.
So, what is even more difficult to solve is
that this explanation happens in a way that
we can interpret.
An earlier approach used decision trees that
described what the learner looks at and how
it uses this information to arrive to a conclusion.
This new work is quite different.
For instance, imagine that a neural network
would look at all the information we know
about a patient and tell us that this patient
likely has the flu.
And, in the meantime, it could tell us that
the fact that the patient has a headache and
sneezes a lot contributed to the conclusion
that he has the flu, but, the lack of fatigue
is notable evidence against it.
Our doctor could take this information and
instead of blindly relying on the output,
could make a more informed decision.
A fine example of a case where AI does not
replace, but augment human labor.
An elegant tool for a more civilized age.
Here, we see an example image where the classifier
explains which region contributes to the decision
that this image depicts a cat, and which region
seems to be counterevidence.
We can use this not only for tabulated patient
data and images, but text as well.
In this other example, we try to find out
whether a piece of written text is about Christinanity
or Atheism.
Note that the decision itself is not as simple
as looking for a few keywords, even a mid-tier
classifier is much more sophisticated than
that.
But, it can tell us about the main contributing
factors.
A big additional selling point is that this
technique is model agnostic, which means that
it can be applied to other learning algorithms
that are able to perform classification.
It is also a possibility that an AI is only
right by chance, and if this is the case,
we should definitely know about that.
And here, in this example, with the additional
explanation, it is rather easy to find out
that we have a bad model that looks at the
background of the image and thinks it is the
fur of a wolf.
The tests indicate that humans make significantly
better decisions when they lean on explanations
that are extracted by this technique.
The source code of this project is also available.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!